for 40 years franced Ford coppler has
been trying to make a particular sci-fi
movie and he got so bored of waiting for
a studio to help him he decided to pay
for it himself welcome to cyre your
SciFi TV and Movie
Channel megalopolis is a hard word to
say try saying that really quickly after
you've had a couple of drinks I think
you'll struggle I before this video
spent about 10 minutes going megalopolis
megalopolis alop and I just about
managed to say at the start of this
video so I'm quite pleased with myself
but this is a movie that has been in
franced Ford Copper's brain for four
decades he's been desperately trying to
get a studio to make it but nobody would
step up so he decided to self Finance it
but what is this megalopolis movie and
who is in it when are we going to see on
our screens and what does it mean for
the future of Hollywood well well in a
recent interview Adam Driver who is one
of the main stars of the movie has been
talking about it and he has been
praising it he said it has been one of
the nicest experiences he's ever had on
set he said it is actually beautifully
made and he cannot wait for this movie
to come out because he really does think
it's going to be a feast of the eyes and
the Brain he thinks this will be Francis
Ford Copper's Masterpiece and he has
made me incred incredibly excited about
this potential project he's basically
said look because Franc for cppa is
having to finance this himself he is not
at the beck and call of any executive
he's having no ridiculous demands put on
him by a studio there is no demands for
this to make money as it were there is
just the demand of making a good movie
franced Ford coppler is allowing himself
by putting his money on the line to
create what he wants now that is
incredibly exciting proposition but who
else is in the movie well Adam Driver
Aubry Plaza she abuff and Natalie
Emanuel are the main stars but this is
also going to have Dustin Hoffman
Lawrence Fishburn John Voit James lar
and Forest Whitaker now having a sh of
buff in a movie is actually pretty brave
in itself I actually think if a studio
was involved he might have struggled
with that bit of casting Shila Buff for
me is actually an excellent actor and I
after the Transformers movie in
particular thought he was going to go
off and be a big star now he had a few
personal issues he didn't like being a
celebrity as much as maybe others would
and he's he's definitely the sort of
actor that takes the craft of acting
very very
seriously sometimes I would argue too
seriously Aubrey plazer as well is an
actress that that I love her in every
interview of scenery she might be insane
but she's insane in like an adorable way
and Natalie Emmanuel is actually an
English actress that's really her star
is rising and again she'll be excellent
in this so what is the movie actually
about well it's a post-apocalyptic movie
we've never seen one of those before but
it's actually a post-apocalyptic movie
with a bit of a Twist so New York has
actually been virtually destroyed by
some sort of disaster we don't know if
it's a natural disaster or or they'll
probably throw in something to do a
global warming or something um to be
honest a massive flood would make sense
because New York keeps flooding anyway
so something like that would make sense
but an architect one of probably Adam
Drive If we're honest an architect is
planning to turn the old city into a new
Utopia so he's planning to build a city
that would be a Utopia for the residents
to live in but there is a problem the
existing mayor is fighting against him
now we have to speculate a little bit on
why anybody would fight against wanting
to build a
Utopia it's probably for political
ideological reasons If we're honest
because a lot of people consider
something like living in a Utopia to be
a bit liberal and a bit communist so um
there probably are political ideologies
that go against whatever it is that the
architect in is planning to do but also
I imagine there probably going to be
business the are going to be very
wealthy people that probably don't want
a utopian society where everyone's equal
and everybody gets enough food enough
work and everything else so I think
there's going to be really political
reasons again why somebody is fighting
against this utopian
plan I think this storyline is
fascinating and really does allow the
film Creator to explore many aspects
both the positive and the negative of
the human Psych and our culture it
really should show us the dark
underbelly and the things about
ourselves we don't really like and how
that actually people on the surface want
to do better and we want to strive and
we want to be good but how often we fail
and the reasons behind why we
fail if you're enjoying the video don't
forget to like subscribe hit that thumbs
up leave a comment and all those things
but also go and check us out on
patreon.com cidre most of our videos do
premere there first this video actually
premiered nearly 10 hours before it did
on YouTube and a lot of our videos
actually premiere 24 hours before they
do on YouTube so go over check that out
because a lot of people sadly even you
don't want to admit it are selfish
greedy and well a lot of the time quite
unkind so I think this movie really does
get to explore those aspects of people's
personalities and our culture it is
actually a really brilliant mechanism
for doing that and this is when sci-fi
is at its best now sci-fi for me should
always have layers to it there should
always be meanings behind the story if
you want to do just a boring movie about
some political Intrigue or something do
a political Intrigue movie but if you
want to make that story interesting make
it into a sci-fi movie if you want to
talk about people's emotions do a movie
about emotions but if you want to make
that interesting make it into a sci-fi
movie sci-fi really is the greatest
medium for
exploring things like this that can be
quite boring or can be quite you know
difficult for us to process in ways that
is not only interesting exciting but
also that makes you think when a sci-fi
movie is at its best it changes you and
I think this is the sort of movie
that will change the audience that you
will come out of it maybe thinking just
a little bit differently but the rain
reason why I'm so excited about this
movie mecopa trolopoulos there is no
pressure from a studio there is no
pressure from Executives that are
desperate for this to be a hit for them
to keep their jobs there is no big fat
cat stressing about their return at the
box office all there is is a film cre
creating his vision for me if your name
is Francis Ford cppa you really
shouldn't have a problem getting your
movie made but unfortunately in the
Modern Age if they don't see a return
they ain't going to invest and that
means we're not going to see movies like
this a movie that Francis Ford cppa
let's let that sink in it's not bill
from you know accounting trying to make
this movie it's Francis Ford cppa why
aren Earth wouldn't the studios back it
because they're cowards and because they
can't see a financial return basically
so this is one of the most exciting
projects 40 years in the making I can
think of ever and when megatop opad Opus
does come out at the cinema please
please go and see it I cannot tell you
how excited I am about this movie but I
would love for you to tell me what you
think so please get across in comments
is
megalopolis a mie you would love to see
and at the end of the day this could be
a project that changes Hollywood
potentially forever if it makes money
for one maybe the studios will take
notice but also could it Inspire other
creators to maybe take that leap
themselves and self fund a project or
get funding in other ways for projects
that they desperately want to make are
there creators out there right now that
have had an idea brewing in the back of
their heads for 10 years or more but
don't have the brave y to push ahead
with could Francis Ford cppa be about to
inspire them and I should say as well
this isn't a project that is never going
to happen they are filming it now it is
going to happen and megalopolis will
eventually be in
cinemas I can't wait but get into the
comments and tell me exactly what you
think about it if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also so you can go to patreon.com
sidre where most of our new videos do
Premiere first and you get to see them
without the adverts you lucky bunnies
finally go to c.co which is our
dedicated website and we do articles
based on a lot of our videos so we try
and add a little bit more information
there for you to digest to please check
it out as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next
[Music]
time